Alec Gillis and Tom Woodruff jr. are the
effects artists behind some of the most
famous movie creatures of the past 30
years they've been at the frontier of
practical effects since starting their
company studio Adi in the late 80s but
there was a time when the rise of CGI
threatened to make them suddenly
obsolete Alec and Tom first met back in
1985 when practical effects were pretty
much the only effects they were
connected through their shared mentor
the FX legend Stan Winston that's when
we sort of got together and realized
that we shared a lot of interest it
brought us to wanting to do monster we
had so much in common that we kind of
had this bond after founding Adi in 1988
the two quickly made a name for
themselves as the guys that top
directors could turn to whenever they
needed help bringing unusual characters
to life Adi is in-house artists oversee
every stage of a character's development
they start with the concept design then
create all the makeup puppets or
animatronics that the character requires
when it's time to film Tom will often
step into a suit to play a character
himself while Alec and his team of
puppeteers control any mechanical
elements behind the scenes so we work
together it's like through every step of
the way to up to the point where we get
that image on film just five years after
starting Adi Alec and Tom won an Oscar
for their work on the character of
Madeline Ashton the walking talking
courts played by Meryl Streep in death
becomes her to create Madeline's
distorted proportions adi builds
programmed and shot a number of
animatronic duplicates for Meryl they
programmed the head with a lip sync
animation the result was incredible
from there ad I kept taking on new
challenges and animatronics they made
their first motion control creature with
Goro for the martial arts movie mortal
kombat this is the version of Goro
you'll find in the Mortal Kombat comics
and video games Tom and Alec wanted the
live-action Goro to be more realistic
which wasn't an easy feat considering
that he's a giant warrior with four arms
they decided to make a practical
fighting suit and put Tom inside it
while Tom controlled groves lower arms
from inside the suit Alec and five other
puppeteers operated the upper arms head
face and neck which were all mechanical
this is called a telemetry device that
is the mechanical contraption that is
worn by a puppeteer and all the
movements that that puppeteer makes are
translated to Goro's upper arm things
weren't exactly easy for Tom inside the
125 pound suit tubes running up the
interior were his only source of fresh
air or water for hours at a time there
was no room for air slits or eye holes
so he used a small video screen to see
his surroundings plus he could only
communicate with Alec via radio by using
a small microphone inside the suit it
was quite an undertaking for us it was
an amazing feat of technology that we'd
built very early on but soon ad i's
achievements began to be overshadowed by
advancements in the digital realm what
we were doing in the 80s and we were the
rockstars of the guys behind the scenes
in the moment where the industry was
starting to rush into CGI it was a very
sobering moment and they would say you
guys are going to be out of work
luckily directors soon realized that
practical effects still had a place in
movies when CGI made its foray into
really big popular movies like Jurassic
Park we also learned that they needed an
animatronic a practical a thing to help
support what the audience was seeing at
digital imagery because it just helped
completely paint a realistic picture for
the audio the nice thing about that was
that it gave us the opportunity to work
on more movies that without CGI would
never
made look at Starship Troopers that we
worked on as an example where until the
advent of computer technology there was
no way to get thousands of bug creatures
running across the surface of a planet
adi built an army of giant bugs for
starship troopers earning tom and alec
their third Oscar nod fair effects the
main technique to execute the creatures
was CGI but there were moments that
benefited by real pieces when people
could be picked up and chopped in half
by giant actual mechanical bugs because
there's nothing like having the real
thing there on set lately Hollywood is
returning to that idea that nothing
beats the real thing on screen Tom and
Alec are sometimes even asked to create
characters the old way with makeup and
prosthetics work that may be simple but
is no less terrifying a perfect example
is the Pennywise the atf design for the
it moving they started with sketches
from director andy muskie idea it was
our job to transpose andy's design onto
bill's guards guards lifecast you know
the great thing about this design that I
think is so brilliant is that it turns
Pennywise into a child that was the goal
here was to make him look like almost a
toddler it had a sort of a bigger head
like very young you know children would
happen we gave him a little button nose
and we gave him these cute little teeth
with these little kind of like bunny
incisors but it was all in and working
with this hideous clown would cracked
paint we rounded out his cheeks and
rounded out his nose but then we gave it
that texture of decrepit decay which is
what makes him extra creepy of course
the thing that really brings it to life
is Bill skarsgård performance I cannot
think of a choice it would have been any
better as a penny wise and Bill
skarsgård he looked like a computer
effect
it's his mouth just went like this I got
chills in the and the makeup girl are
watching it these days as directors
increasingly choose to incorporate
practical effects alongside CGI Tom and
Alec have no shortage of work it's like
a revolving door of young directors
commune say whatever this project is
I've got to work with you guys I've got
to do Adi so we have never been in a
better position to bring our kind of
style and our kind of life to all of the
different elements well I think what
makes us work so well as collaborators
is that we both have a complete passion
right a complete love for the genre what
we act let me to are things about
characters people in income incredible
situations and with incredible things
happening to them are happening from
them
you